hello there internet friend and welcome
to the point it's episode 10 of season
2 we're just a few days away from the
biggest week in video game news and most
of our staff and equipment is already
down in
La so hold on to your butts it's time
for the electronic triple E3 is just the
weirdest thing think about it every year
people around the world people of
different races and genders people with
perhaps nothing else in common sit in
front of their computers and watch a
bunch of Rich guys talk about video
games that their companies are going to
bring out over the coming years we sit
in our rooms connected to each other via
Twitter neoa Reddit and chat rooms we
gasp Shake our heads and punch the sky
because of words coming out of an
executive's mouth announcements of games
that we might not see for years price
drops bundles returning favorites new
IPS E3 is on next week and what that
usually meant for me was taking a bunch
of time off work one year I was working
as an errand boy and couldn't get the
time off so I spent the day hiding in
the back of a web Cafe next to the bank
I was supposed to be delivering
documents for today I am part of a very
privileged group of people who get to
experience E3 firsthand instead of
watching the streams on Gamespot like I
did for 7 years I'm going to be the one
sitting on the stage interviewing
developers while they demo their games
and to be honest though I get to see a
lot of games up close and browse the
boots myself taking an E3 from the
comfort of your computer screen gives
you a much clearer view of what's
Happening across the Expo so for those
of you who are taking time off to enjoy
the Expo or maybe some of you who have
never experienced E3 before here is your
guide to what's happening when it's
happening and the hottest rumors ah
heading into E3 E3 starts on Monday with
press conferences from a number of
companies all of which will be streamed
on gamespot.com first up
Microsoft Microsoft get the party
started at 930 in the morning local time
so as the British and Irish should be
coming in from work at around 5:30 p.m.
what can we expect well Microsoft are
likely to te their new connect console
while throwing a bone to some connect
developers I wouldn't be surprised to
see harmonics on stage at some point we
should hopefully see some gameplay of
Halo 5 Guardians Quantum break and there
good money on Black Tusk showing off
their new Gears of War Game hopefully
rare will make an appearance and we'll
probably see some more Fable Legends and
Sunset Overdrive rumors are r that we'll
see Rise to but I'm not really sure if
anyone cares electronic
artists sports
games EA kicks off at noon Pacific
that's APM GMT they've confirmed a bunch
of games mirrors Edge 2 a new game from
the alien Criterion Studios creators of
burnout plus nearly half a dozen new
games BioWare and visceral games
creators of Dead Space are known to be
working on new games too so perhaps
something new from them maybe a new Mass
Effect expect the usual array of FIFA
Madden and other sports games along with
Battlefield Hardline Star Wars
Battlefront Sims 4 and Dragon Age
Inquisition also expected to start L
because that's how EA roll and cross
your fingers that Peter Moore does
another impromptu comedy act before the
show goes live because his bit at
Gamescom was actually pretty good you
beis suck UB Ubisoft the French guys the
French guys Ubisoft hits the stage at
300 p.m. La time so that's 11: at night
for those of you in the UK and Ireland
and they've already confirmed a bunch of
games Far Cry 4 Assassin's Creed Unity
the crew and Tom Clan's the division so
the big questions are how will those
games look will the division be the same
game we saw last year or was that just a
tech demo will Unity bring real
Revolution to the Assassin's Creed
formula or is it just another scene
change how much multiplayer is really in
Far Cry 4 and does anyone even care
about the crew in terms of rumor it's
likely they'll have some new IPS up
their sleeves and I wonder if perhaps
Ubisoft melier will finally get the
showof gameplay for Beyond Good and Evil
2 Ubisoft have also confirmed that there
will be special guests on stage and
judging by recent performances by Mr
cine want to come over and play my Wii
and Aisha girlwood Tyler I'm so freaking
amp expect the whole conference to be
pretty weird and or irritating Sony
Computer
Entertainment Sony's conference RS out
the first day and this is when the folus
in Europe have to decide whether they're
going to be tired as hell for work the
next day 6:00 p.m. La time means 2: a.m.
GMT so what have they got well Sony have
confirmed we'll see more of the order
1866 which is by the way looking pretty
great expect Drive Club The Last of Us
remasters another Peak at the new
Uncharted game and maybe something new
from Sony Santa Monica media molecule
have already confirmed that they won't
be showing editing at E3 but we may get
more of a look at the mysterious Project
Beast I know it sounds trike to say it
at this stage but it really really
really sounds like the Last Guardian is
going to make an appearance this year
most likely on PS4 and David cage is
probably working on some sort of
interactive sex game where everyone has
French accents so look out for that
Nintendo do you want one of these H
Nintendo will be streaming all week from
the show floor and giving in-depth demos
of some of their titles so their
announcements may come as more of a
trickle than a torrent but they do have
a pre-recorded press conference their
digital event being streamed from 9:00
a.m. on Tuesday morning so 5:00 p.m. in
GMT land what will they show well
probably Super Smash Brothers Bayonetta
2 Hyrule Warriors Pokemon Omega Ruby and
Alpha Sapphire rumors suggest we'd also
see a new 3DS game Mario Party U and a
new Star Fox for Wii U good money on the
new Zelda being shown off too there have
also been a lot of talk about them
showing off new hardware this year the
failure of the Wii U is a known quantity
at this stage but it would be crazy to
think that a brand new console would be
unveiled perhaps this is the new quality
of life product they keep talking about
I guess we'll see in a few days and then
E3 proper starts the doors open at noon
on Tuesday and Gamespot starts streaming
from the stage show floor we'll have two
live stages on Tuesday Wednesday and
Thursday demoing a bunch of games you
know about and a bunch you've not heard
of yet let us know in the comments what
games you hope will be revealed and be
sure to join us live all next week from
the comfort of your own ass over on
gamespot.com
E3 all eyes on me in the club see them
all looking at me Fe into touch lady
baby
hello yes yeah don't worry we're going
to be live at E3 we don't have an
episode of the point next week oh I know
myself and and you're going to be
shooting you know behind St behind the
scenes for the whole thing and we're
going to do the next the point will be
about E3
yeah did that work one more cuz that was
fun electronic
artists Sports G
that sexy Scottish guy that was in the
the the show today that's Cameron
Robinson yeah he's got that really hot
sign show reality check it's on
gamespot.com every week okay I got to go
yeah no they need to sign they don't
have to sign at La I got to I got to get
the sign I got to get
the of attention but the is to the rare
when I'm in the room why your team
disappear that girl let me speak in ear
ready